edouard philippe annoncé cette semaine
les mesures qui allaient être prises en
vue de la reprise progressive de
l'activité des français le 11 mai
prochain si de nombreux salariés vont
reprendre le chemin du travail
l'une des plus grosses craintes du
gouvernement et la situation dans les
transports en commun le premier ministre
a d'ailleurs décidé de prendre des
mesures dans ce cas particulier le port
du masque sera rendue obligatoire dans
tous les transports métro en bus mais
pour compléter ces gestes barrières
edouard philippe a également annoncé
qu'un siège sur deux serait condamnée
dans le métro pour permettre une
distanciation sociale suffisante
immédiatement les équipes de la ratp ont
réagi et commencer à mettre en oeuvre le
plan décidé par le gouvernement en
préparation du 11 mai et pour condamner
ces sièges la ratp a décidé non pas de
les retirer mais d'apposer dessus un
autocollant visiblement fier de sa
stratégie pour lutter contre la
propagation du virus le groupe ratp a
tweeté le message suivant la ratp débute
la pose d'autocollants sur le réseau
pour le respect des gestes-barrières une
technique qui n'a visiblement pas
convaincu grand monde
alors des stickers pour éviter que les
gens se rapprochent dans le métro
efficace aux inutiles alors est ce que
vous croyez que c'est efficace parce que
vous pensez que c'est inutile
des stickers pour éviter que les gens se
rapprochent dans le métro efficace ou
inutiles alors ça je vous le dis déjà là
sur les réseaux sociaux ça commence ça
réagit de partout là dessus valérie
bénaïm mâché rivasi où est charlie vas-y
mathieu est évidemment absolument
inutile je pense que et voilà les gens
on table sur le civisme des gens moi je
veux bien croire au civisme des genres
et la bonne volonté des gens un jour
deux jours mais un moment la vivre on se
trouve à un moment on court après son
métro pour coup après son crâne parce
qu'on va travailler un moment rentrer de
huit heures de boulot on est fatigué on
a envie de s'asseoir et un pauvre
stickers c'est pas ça qui va vous faire
vous vous arrêtez vous poser ou pas vous
poser franchement il aurait dû trouver
autre chose mais ce n'est pas à la
hauteur d'une pandémie mondiale ce n'est
pas l'homme de la situation actuelle
c'est pas ça qui va résoudre le problème
vraiment alors gérald n'est pas d'accord
géraldine n'est pas d'accord avec vous
bien beau mais ça va pas résoudre le
problème et pour autant c'est utile pour
le temps pourtant tout pour la pédagogie
je me souviens au début quand on regarde
et avec beaucoup de mépris
les italiens faire la queue avec une
distanciation sociale dans les
supermarchés pour les regarder en disant
oh la la qu'est-ce que c'est ridicule
n'empêche qu'aujourd'hui on a aussi nous
et des scotchs devant nos supermarchés
on est en distanciation sociales ont
fait rentrer que peu de personnes dans
les supermarchés et on n'a pas le choix
maintenant le métro effectivement
le premier ministre parle de
distanciation social moi ça me fait
doucement rire parce que je prends le
métro un petit peu pas beaucoup un petit
peu à des heures pas de pointe en plus
c'est souvent je croise gilles
d'ailleurs sur la ligne 10 effectivement
à 17 heures il n'y a pas grand monde
dans le métro quand on y va
mais je sais que ma fille qui prend le
métro tous les matins pour aller à
l'école effectivement là c'est bondé
effectivement ce principe de
distanciation social dans le métro
effectivement on sait que c'est une
concentration de personnes et que
forcément le virus explose dans ces
moments là mais pour autant on n'a pas
le choix
quand on regarde en asie ils le font
quand on regarde en italie aujourd'hui
ils font ça je ne sont ni des
autocollants huit mois environ a dit
justement géraldine en italie où la
crise a été très sévère vous allez voir
que tout se passe bien dans le métro les
distances sont respectés ils ont fait la
même chose que ce qui va se passer en
france
et oui regardez bien on est très très
loin de la ligne 13 en heure de pointe
donc voilà je vous dis moi je pense que
aussi peut-être que les français ils
vont faire comme les italiens on l'est
on est là on a on est on est pas au
départ et vous y tenez à jour on va
regarder marib à regarder et oui heures
de pointe dans le métro de milan en ces
temps de confinement ce n'est pas la
place qui manque mais sur ces sièges
vides un message attire notre attention
je peux m'asseoir ici
non non non pas ici ici non plus cette
dame n'est pas juste désagréable elle ne
fait qu'appliquer les règles c'est
important pour que tout le monde
respecte les distances c'est aussi
important que le masque des gants on se
laver les mains sur les rangées les deux
sièges du milieu doivent rester vides
c'est écrit en italien et en anglais
objectif garder un mètre au moins entre
chaque usager même avertissement sur le
sol et sur les rampes alors les stickers
est-ce que ça va suffire des stickers
dans le métro il va boire juste à côté
du ciel ce siège ne doit pas d'être pris
will et gilles verdez pour moi c'est non
seulement inutile mais aussi père
tellement stupide et c'est ne pas
connaître le métro que d'envisager sa le
matin les gens ils se bousculent dans le
métro alors on dit oui mais quand vous
verrez le métro plein bas prenez le
suivant mais le suivant à 7,2 euros à 8
heures il est aussi plein donc les gens
ils monteront dans le métro ecommera des
sièges où on peut pas s'asseoir bas tout
le monde pas de
bouh entassés donc ça va créer votre
version dégageant qui doivent aller au
boulot que c'est obligé d'aller au
boulot parce qu'on n'a pas le choix ils
vont être tous entassés deux bouts ça va
être pire cas ce n'est donc c'est une
hérésie ce truc là
ceux qui ont bâti ça ils ont jamais pris
le métro c'est incroyable c'est hyper en
colère géraldine qui veut redonner
j'entends gilles qui déjà dès le départ
condamne le système mais de cloisons
déjà on compte sur d'abord le
télétravail on laisse faire et on incite
les gens le plus possible pour ceux qui
ces costumes à paillettes pas tout le
monde
le reste à la maison et de poursuivre le
télétravail ensuite il ya plus de
touristes dans la capitale
malheureux heureuse malheureusement et
heureusement donc ça fait qu'il ya moins
de gens aussi dans le métro donc mais
évidemment il ya des lignes tendues
comme la ligne 13 ou c'est un vrai point
noir est un vrai problème mais malgré
tout je ne vois pas pourquoi ça marche
dans les autres pays
ça marche en asie pourquoi en asie ce un
match là-bas y à pas d'heure de pointe
là bas les gens vont pas travailler là
bas les gens sont pas responsables
pourquoi nous ça ne marchait pas j'ai
pas dis que c'est la solution idéale
j'ai pas dit que c'était la panacée j'ai
pas dit que c'était sûr que ça
fonctionne à 100% mais malgré tout il va
falloir aussi qu'on s'y habitue à milan
il ya le tourniquet qui s'arrête par
exemple quand là quand le quai est trop
plein c'est à dire que pour que les gens
ne puissent pas rentrer à l'intérieur
mais avec tout le temps ce coach
distanciation sociale on n'a pas le
choix
vous pouvez dire que c'est nul que c'est
bidon que ça marchera jamais que vous
êtes en colère on n'a pas le choix
voilà alors les chéris ya plein de gens
qui veulent scinder ce colon qui vont
vous sauver la vie mdr il ferait mieux
de distribuer des masques et du gel des
gants et tester les gens en même temps
les italiens voient la marque alice
technique s'il vous plaît après je ne
suis pas sûr qu'en italie il existe une
ligne 13 comme la nôtre c'est vrai que
ça réagit énormément mais qu'on trouvait
dans un instant avec la vie de raymond
là-dessus la vie
la vidéo des ébats bening qui ne se
demande pas où est charlie
mais qui se demande comment elle va nous
donner son avis vous dit on se retrouve
et j'ai le temps ici donc deux reprises
les stickers voilà vont-ils suffire
voilà pour éviter que les gens se
rapprochent dans le métro efficace oui
inutile
géraldine pour l'instant y croit valérie
bénaïm non gilles verdez non bâti le
forcené on n'a pas entendu raymond non
plus et rené malleville non plus rené
qu'est ce que tu en penses avant qu'on
ait la vie de raymond et de benji le
forcené alors rené les stickers dans les
transports en commun mais je vais
t'aider en plus que moi avant d'avoir le
bas j'étais chauffeur de bus à marseille
chaque bus il ya quatre places est
réservée
c'est pour les femmes enceintes ou les
personnes âgées mais jamais de la vie
lt place elle était respectée et quand
je disais par ces réserves est super et
il fallait se lever gueuler parce que
même une promesse est jusqu'aux oreilles
ou le personnage est pêcheur avec les
caennais et tous ses biens des gains se
levait pas pareil c'est pour la sécurité
et la securitate d'égout dans le métro
on a eu beau père là c'est pour la
sécurité mais ils vont essayer d'être à
distance mais c'est vrai que bon ils
vont essayer
benjamin castaldi oui donc elle a donc
ils mettent des stickers dont dans les
bus et dans les métros c'est bien connu
que le virus
il s'arrête à la porte du bus et la part
du métro ça qu'on l'aimé des stickers
dans le bus et dans le métro pendant la
guerre on en mai pendant mes pas et puis
l évolution ne remet pas c'est
totalement ridicule franchement ils
saturent ont montré qu'ils vont des
choses c'est senna poids là c'est
n'importe quoi non mais des stickers
alors le virus il s'arrête à la porte du
métro puis après banon mais c'est un à
la porte mais si c'est facile ça arrive
c'est sûr évidemment dans le secteur il
est pas là pour arrêter les russes se
trouvent c'est une image plus con que je
ne suis je dit pas ça je vous ai de
faire passer pour un mec débit puisque
je ne suis pas à cyril je vous n'aviez
vraiment que c'est juste et ça ça n'a
pas de sens de faire ça dans les rames
de métro et dans les bus alors que les
ans on vont être brassée dans les gares
brasser dans un abribus
ça n'a pas de sens on sait toutefois
être une distance d'un médecin quant à m
pourquoi il met des stickers et un
panneau bien d'un drogué attention vous
êtes trop près alors qui va répondre
alors pourquoi alors pour force m'a mis
devant tous les supermarchés de france
d'europe et du monde
des stickers ou mais en tout cas des
autocollants pour respecter une
distanciation devant les caisses des
supermarchés pourquoi on a mis ça alors
puisque tout le monde respecte toi
disant ça parce que encore une la
pédagogie ça permet juste d'avoir une
sorte de petit signal pour rappeler aux
gens qu'il faut pas être trop près les
uns des autres
voilà j'ai pas dit que c'était
miraculeux parce que je vous rappelle
que dans les transports on aura aussi
des masques et du gel hydroalcoolique
c'est à dire que c est la distanciation
et le mas et le gel bon alors après vous
vous le condamnez d'office comme ça en
disant que tu as ans et sénat renâcle ça
ne sert à rien que c'est une blague
moi j'ai tendance à penser que de toute
façon on n'a pas le choix et on fera le
mieux possible comme on a essayé de
faire le mieux possible pour respecter
le bon film en est bon on fera le mieux
possible pour respecter ça aussi dans le
métro ou dans les bus mais ce ne sera
pas évident c'est sur l'or n'a pas le
choix raymond on n'a pas connu la
girondine a raison c'est doux rêveur
mais elle a raison faut laisser sa
chance au produit un stickers tu peux le
mettre
ça n'empêche pas sur un quai de métro un
stickers tu peux l'avoir et tu peux
laisser une distance d'un mètre sur un
quai de métro
mais gilles a dit l'ady gil le métro il
va arriver avec déjà des gens dedans ça
veut dire qu'il faudra remettre les gens
aussi que ta mission qu'est située à 16
sur deux les gens ils vont pas reçu ils
vont pas dire je monte pas dans le métro
parce qu'il est plein ils vont montrer
comme ils vont monter quand même et
responchous boucau les deux bouts ils
laisseront les sièges mais reste trop
collé debout parce que quand tu rates
une choré pont d'une correspondance de
métro a peut-être raté sa correspondance
de l'arrière derrière et a peut-être
raté ton bus en fin de parcours qui va
faire que tu vas rentrer chez toi
et là on revient à ce qu'a dit b menahem
tout à l'heure valérie ne va pas rentrer
chez toi à minuit juste parce que tu as
laissé passer quatre métro parce qu'on a
dit il ya un stickers qui n'habitent pas
t'asseoir ça c'est dans la dans le monde
magique des politiques c'est vrai à
l'assemblée c'est bien les stickers mais
dans la vraie vie le matin à 7 heures du
matin parfois elle au charbo tu verras
les maîtres montrons quand même dans le
métro et les images revient sur les
images on voit les images d'un métro à
milan où il ya personne dedans à quelle
heure tu as été je suis pas sûr qu'en
géraldine parle de l'asie ça se passe en
asie
moi je les crois plus tout ce qui se
passe en asie tout ce qui se passe en
chine
4000 morts en chine arrêtez de vous
[ __ ] de ma gueule avec les chaînes
d'info qui m'ont
des idées des désirs la même avenue sud
et à taïwan et hong kong
je crois plus géré a dirigé le film nous
ont mis dans la merde depuis décembre il
savait qu'il y avait quand on a un virus
nous avons aussi moi j'attends de voir
ce doux rêveur c'est comme géraldine les
stickers ça coûte rien j'attends de voir
et les français peut-être pour sauver
leur vie bah ils feront mentir c'est ce
sera leur bien gerald il voulait
rebondir ce que désire et mont houy 90
mais j'entends la suspicion
effectivement qu'on n'a pas confiance
moi je fais exactement de votre
situation sauf que aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qu'on fait concrètement pour
éventuellement aller au travail et se
remettre en ordre de marche
on a par exemple demandé on adore on a
par exemple demandé à certains patrons
d'étaler par exemple le début du travail
le matin au lieu d'être convoqué à 8
heures certains seront convoqués à 8
heures d'autres à 9 heures d'autres à 10
heures ça n'est pas évidemment
miraculeux ça ne m'arrive bien forcément
mais ou encore une fois il faut quand
même essayer on n'a pas choisi
d'expliquer puisque comme une situation
totalement inédite et totalement
anxiogène pour tout le monde
effectivement c'est anxiogène de devoir
ans le matin le métro bondé et se dire
[ __ ] qu'est ce que je vais faire et je
vais rentrer comment ce soir et est-ce
que je vais choquer ou est-ce que je
vais acheter évidemment encore une fois
là il va y avoir d avoir des ailes
justement il va y avoir des ratés
évidemment mais on va devoir réadapter
truc au jour le jour
alors de quoi demain sera fait mais
l'orgie croatie est appréciable
incroyable à deux minutes et unia black
mamba qui dit cirilli 3,3 au civisme
français napoléon ce soir chez ba ba en
tout le français un indiscipliné
sionneau sûrement le plus au monde
voilà il ya plein de gens qui disent
voilà qui sonde à ok avec géraldine
maillet mais quand il voit quand ils
vont de sortir les tests c'est comme les
masquant dont on parle depuis deux mois
on n'y croit pas trop voilà oui vraiment
je voulais heureusement je voulais juste
rajouter c'est vrai géraldine à la
raison il faut trouver des solutions les
patrons qui vise à 9 heures à 10 heures
ça c'est bien aussi juste est ce que
c'est la ratp a aussi la clé des fois
y'a des rames tous les trois à 3 6
minutes est-ce que la rate et n'aura pas
la clé en mettre en en étant des rames
qui pour deux minutes où toutes les
trois minutes max ont fait allégeance en
dise c'est pas grave si je laisse passer
celui-là dans une minute ya servi la
nouvelle couleur de points je parle de
7h à 9h est-ce que la ratp peut pas sur
les lignes comme la ligne 13 dire les
métros toutes les 3 à 6 minutes c'est
fini on va en mettre toutes les deux
minutes comme ça les gens
pas peur de laisser passer un métro
peut-être que c'est aussi sa solution
alors vraiment c'est justement tu parles
de ça il ya vallini delvaux la
coordinatrice expérience client a la
ratp qui était au jt de tf1 hier de 20
heures et elle explique comment il
s'organise dans le métro ou à des mois
voilà c'est elle et c'est le casse-tête
des transports regarder nous avons fait
le choix d'être plus sur une série tics
visuels que l'eau répressives à en
comptant bien entendu sur le civisme de
chacun mais le civisme ne pourra pas
grand chose quand il y aura en heures de
pointe six personnes par mètre carré
seule solution réduire le nombre de
voyageurs en temps normal il y en a 5
millions par jour en ile-de-france alors
comment faire en sorte de ne pas
dépasser les 600 mille voyageurs
après le 11 mai il faut premièrement il
y est beaucoup moins de déplacements par
notre travail et deuxième possibilité
est allé les horaires de prise de
travail plutôt qu'ils soient concentrés
entre 8h et 9h30 de faire en sorte que
la plage de deux débuts de travail soit
plutôt de 7h30 à 10h30
alors il ya quelqu'un qui nous lie à
beaumont qui dit raymond le matin bras
gauche tu adores tu dis la vérité tu
connais la vraie vie toi voilà comment
qu'on embrasse gilbert derrick may série
la ratp je les adore mais le 11 mai non
seulement contrairement à ce que raymond
espérer la 10ème et espérait y aura pas
plus de mai qu il y en aura beaucoup
moins il y aura que 70% le 11 mai et les
lignes sont saturés en temps normal
c'est à dire que quand vous êtes à 100%
en heures de pointe c'est archi bondée y
en a 70 % et à partir du 11 mai tout le
monde comme moi c'est les épices et les
pros pour aller bosser
imaginez son rer métro des halles que
les ont laissé un mètre cinquante de
distance que les envois tant que
l'erreur impossible donc ce sommet il
est voué à l'échec
alors s'il vous plaît oui bonsoir rené
bonsoir on est mal vous ici déclare
honnêtement je voudrais comme été que
pourquoi obligations romarin en maudit
ce ne sera pas possible de mettre le
début je voulais mais ton tu plais
malterre moi je voudrais qu'on
m'explique
parce que moi je tiens y'avait j'étais
au dépôt d'armes
il ya du matériel la pagaille il ya des
métros à bahia que tu peux vous faites
en autant au compteur tu peux créer des
emplois demain matin je ne vois pas
pourquoi on ne peut pas doubler ou
tripler les le poids les moyens de
transport là il faut qu'on m'explique
avant d'accord alors ça on va te mettre
en contact avec le ministre des
transports et on va te dire c'est ce que
disait raymond yans instant et peut-être
que peut-être que mine de rien on va
voir ce qui va se passer vous peut-être
y aura plus de transports voilà la clé
ils vont dire qu'il va y avoir 70%
donc ce ne sera pas le moment mais après
peut-être qu'ils vont mettre plus de
métro voilà qui vont plus tournée qui
aura plus de rotations c'est ce qui
n'est pas possible en cause des
téléspectateurs grâce compenser
téléspectateurs tient de ce
de ce ce débat regarder les stickers
efficace à 26% inutile à 74%